I remember very very very very very at the
beginning the discouragement of our
position that cut charity cut
hello I'm honey
hello how are you I'm pedro waves yesterday
hello I'm from land and this what is in
enormous moments of paper
[Laughter]
[Music]
i
[Music  ]
ah
we are going to be the bloody heroes of
all these people
but be very careful
because the moment there is a
single drop of blood this is very
important
as there is only one victim
we will stop being robin hoods to
simply become children
of  [ __ ]
professor
tokio is accredited
and we are going to steal
from the first season that was in
the mint so I was no longer there
and what the exact scene was do you remember
if well those of us who were a bit as
if we were small children in a school
because I remember the desks there we
chose the names of each one and
exactly that first they were planets
then you tell me that we didn't or we didn't
know each other completely no had already begun
to fall everything that c  there then no but
it was also
very early when it started
we had started the first day in
toledo
but
obviously all this follows that
we are still very lost
if we are getting to know each other and according to
our look that counted you did
something like that you turn around  from one
of the camera intros that made
his apiary and asked for them as a
small gesture to formulate the
character I don't know if it was wrong
I was getting pregnant at
the mint the states are a
little more involved honey and I was  other
things were other things it's good the
beginning of the beginning of the
beginning
[Music]
but no and all the time we
all
lose
[Music]
one day
now
is the moment to
throw bills and that we are arriving in
turns
this day was I would tell you  one of the
worst days of the paper house in
filming after they arrive we were also shooting
on the same set that you were
leaving and I was left with exactly this
set and  he set where the day I
put on my shoes and you start crying on my shoulder the 80
objected that was horrible it was very
demanding because we were at the end of the
shoot we are exhausted do you remember they
said cut and we all threw ourselves on the
ground all of us on the ground because we were
exhausted  but
I remember that a moment when
we were really broken
psychologically broken and if I remember
correctly maybe the memory also
amplifies it they began to put me in a
day in what potentially
should have been ordered in three days
why was that  something happened because
we were already out of that last day no no
because it
was like we were filming and we were
doing singing lessons with that woman do
you remember that we got bread from the ax or and
we had to sing it because I
had already sung it before
I had classes like quenas now  a little
as I know
and it was very hard because we were
tired because we were in a hurry
because emotionally it was also very
intense and we got there  on to shoot
tomás without painting cut because we were
wasting time and an agreement of this moment of
delirium well it was that there was a shot that
lasted about 15 minutes if it was
barbaric and from córdoba jesús to culminate
with level of intensity it's not like not
walking with intensity name  No,
but on the other hand, it was a very
emotional day. I think it was the day
I saw the whole team cry,
but because of the tiredness that there
was and that everyone seemed to be in
situations of very powerful emotions
because it was the  well ending I don't know if I'm
mixing memories but I remember it the way
I think we shot that day
we shot several different scenes
because I also had that
horrible scene that horrible horrible scene
for my character I mean where
moscow told me it was a black hole
that  Wherever it happened,
people died and it worried us, do you remember
that scene was very strong, so if it was
a complicated day
[Music]
come on, it bleeds us a lot that I have seen
that they nailed him they joined members in
grams where I was
good if you come
or if it's
okay this is this is actually
quite exciting because I started the
series having only a script for
chapters 1 and 2 and at the end of chapter
2 at least of the montage  The initial one
ended in chapter 2 I received the
shot, we didn't know exactly where it
was or how it would turn out and I thought that
they were going to kill me there I don't remember
that perfectly before I had a
very strange mixture because on the one hand it was
like hockey  cool to have entered this
project so cool and it will depend
on [ __ ] two chapters and they don't kill me
well then all of a sudden I went to dinner with
some friends at a Mexican restaurant and
they tell me boy when I enter you are this the
cbo I yes of course just like this  now it's more
common but before it wasn't so much I
already know if you're in the paper house and I
thought if we're giving the first
chapter this person knows how you
tell me I'm from the script team and it was
like  jolín clarified that good to such and
I then at dinner all the time there is
a margarita I saw the second margarita
and I went a month and I told him please don't
kill me it's that I'm having a good time and
now I think about it and say [ __ ]  but if it
was [ __ ], it
was strong in the story and especially
then how it has been evolving and everything
I now think about it many times I say
my goodness that we are finishing that is
the last one we shot I said here
we are closing the fifth season you
know if  I thought they were going to kill you in
the second chapter
i
[Music] come
down
I'm not going to kill you
and I'm not going to torture you either
i
[Music]
let me ask you something because
this has to be the end of something
it couldn't be the beginning  of a
beautiful friendship
[Music]
a love sequence clearly
we remember perfect it almost
killed me that I was complete you are
making me very nervous yes yes I remember
that you because pedro does those things
you know
in sequence if you have it obvious  r
he takes care that you really hate him
and and that I wasn't feeling well anymore you
remember that
I wasn't fine anymore
I wasn't there to be pushed on
a stretcher to be gagged and
put duct tape all over my
body  I wasn't swollen at all because of
the energy, but the number because I was there,
yes, besides, I already notice it a lot in
the scenes where people see it, they're going to
see it, I was swollen and I think it gave me
a sort of stress outbreak,
but  There was a moment when Pedro, well, I
don't know, he told me things about the mouse, so I
was completely angry
, I'm sorry, [ __ ], very, very angry, very
angry
, I mean, he was provoking it for the
scene, but now it also came in handy for me
as a bit of personal therapy, as well as
for  take out everything that I had been accumulating
for a little while and pedro m
didn't laugh in my face and he made me so
thankful to
take bites and I told you I was about
to see my album it's that I couldn't move
and the guy was  I put here and  I told you the
next time you do this to me and we weren't
on take you remember I wasn't recording
I told you the next time you do
this to me it bites your face what beautiful
memories do
you remember
bite us if you can water
[Music]
I personally think that  It hasn't
evolved in the
way I would have liked. I think that in
a situation like this, the way to
react is not what happened
later in the series, but it was a
character that I loved madly and I ended up as if to
say, well, I don't understand very well either.
how do you get here after all that, I mean, I
never understood why he did what he did
or why he suddenly came to tokyo and
didn't even have a loving reaction
[Music]
we always told each other the truth while [ __ ]
but you don't always want to hear the
truth
[Music]
I can't go on with you
I've been thinking a lot
I always follow in front and behind a little
dog when when he sees Tokyo or
when we're in the bathtub that you
have everything painted that l  or he goes like this
when you leave me this garden of course I didn't
understand the character he stays stiff
look girl bye-bye there was something there that
didn't finish fascinating me nor did it seem like
a realistic reaction to my setting up this
place
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Music  ]
and he has spent his life being a bit of a son
of a [ __ ] but there
I think I feel like dying with dignity
no no
the death of berlin
seen from now on great news
great news because it generated a lot of
vertigo but I think it gave flight
to the character that  she made me review many
things from another dimension, that is, it was
a gift yes it is true that when
we later had to continue the series I was
very afraid of conversations for
conversations she is what I thought
I would be able to defend the
character that was given to me  the character was going to die
but not because he had death
but because how am I going to defend a
character who was the pure present and
pure chaos and suddenly he is dead and I am going
to be in the past all the current
pu  nch that I had a character I lost it
but
I think I'm not going to sustain it and I think
it's not going to be possible however I
did it and by far
well I eat all the moments of a
lot of insecurity of a lot of vertigo of a
lot of uncertainty of patti no no
I maintain that he is not incapable of defending it,
but it is true that he forced me to
have to reinvent myself
to put myself to the test and many times
going blind, that is, one never knows where
a gift can be found, despite
his ideas, it is something that also goes  to pass
varieties of television I say this is
impossible the logic to do this this
does not hold and suddenly there just
appeared something that led you to go
beyond your limitations lit of
possibilities and therefore a contrast well
a doll inside a  doll of
a doll that resizes what
you were doing I think this is
something like what all the
characters from the paper house have in common I think we
've all been in that moment of
vertigo  but how can I defend this
if I can't even believe it, I mean how
am I going to do something like that and fortunately
thanks to that it's like if you get
over that situation suddenly find
small gifts
I tell you I've had five
divorces like that  occasion five divorces
five times that I believed in love
and finding the way fascinates this
profession so difficult to explain
sometimes and it is that many of the
difficulties that the actor has have
an echo with the situation of what is
happening totally there is a moment  in
which a totally very reasonable transfer is made
that also
makes sense but suddenly
begins to have an echo with the
delirium of what is happening in the
plot the situation itself and it is true
that in this series at
times  it is amplified because we are
shooting confinement
as best we can we are not prolonging this
question much but I find
this topic very interesting because I just
remembered also with this that h  As you said,
the click came to me. Do you remember the
scene I had with Nairobi that we
hit each other in the classroom. She took us to
her room and apologized. I
knocked on the door and she told me the
whole story about going upstairs and we ended up
dancing and  doing a dance challenge and that
not even doing you erkin drinking tequila
well a very crazy thing happened
to me and it always happened to me with tokio
that I was embarrassed the moment
she opened the door for me I ask at the
door and she is angry  with me he
told me go away and I went in and sat
next to the bed my body retracted to
go to that bed I was embarrassed but
I'm embarrassed he uses me and now you've
said that those are those things that a
boy bears because I'm not here  connected to
my t actions is that it doesn't even
have to do with the character that
[Music]
happens to not exceed the state
what happened there was a confirmation
that for me the series are living beings we
must already  I have it and I'm going  with the
autopilot thing that I never
understand but I remember that this
occurred to us if I remember correctly Álvaro said
that we could be brothers in an
Italian
brothers
do not you think that we are here it is that he
has a reading level that
is so high and then we are
Speaking like this a little casually, no,
and suddenly I arrived, that is to eat,
I have to be here talking how he
would speak, let's go, brother, he tells him what to
say, what are you saying, but it's for the pot,
but it's no joke or I know that this is
impossible.
brothers,
because it really doesn't connect, that is, it does
n't connect, it's the level we're going to
work on later, if it's what they claimed,
but but we're not rotating, it
suddenly has a level of resonance
that is much more powerful and then the
conversation went as if it were
leading  little by little and a month
later maybe my mind came somewhere but a
month later the
writers came and they began to
write it and incorporate it into the lyrics
so that was something that was not  s we meet
in the process
and then something has been configured because
I don't care who came up with
that, it's up in the air but they are
things that rush in and can be
picked up or not
because suddenly there is a predisposition
to play with  this type of accident and
that type of accident has configured
something that is decisive for me and
that is that in the end the paper house is a whole
family
and
I said that same person I told Álex
Pinal and I said I remember I think something
of  sexual tension must exist between
these two people something must happen
between these two at least I imagine
suddenly hooking up that time and then
saying what the [ __ ] happened you know and that
was when they wrote about when one
day he had me tied up which was almost like
half
hot-blooded sexuality in things
well guys it has been a pleasure to be able to
chat with you about these
moments in the paper house it has been very
emotional what we have
had a trip
so if it occurs to you  any other
super scene that you want to remember
we can be with you again
bye bye